We've all heard penguins mate for life, but
in reality nature doesn't DO monogamy.
Hey animals, thanks for stopping by DNews,
I'm Trace!
Humans tend to personify pretty much every
other creature on this planet, and with love
being one of our more desired emotions -- we
REALLY WORK to see it in nature.
We really don't have to look that far, to
see some of the happiness we hope for in ourselves.
Plenty of animals, like penguins, are monogamous,
but even penguins will cheat on their partners
in some species and situations.
True mammal monogamy is rare, only 3 to 5
percent of the 5,000 mammals do it, but there
are some monogamous heroes out there.
For example, the MOST monogamous bird is the
albatross.
Albatross flirt by dancing, which they learn
from hanging around with older albatrosses.
This all sounds oddly familiar...
They'll go out dancing with lots of partners
until they find the right one and when they
do, they pair up forever.
A mated pair of albatross can be apart for
months, and will still return to nest at the
same time.
They cuddle with each other and never snapchat
with anyone else.
They never divorce, no matter what -- even
if the male does the dirty bird with another
lady.
Yes, the males DO cheat, but they'll stay
together.
Gibbons are the closest human relatives who
mate for life, finding a mate when they're
young and trying to make it work for the kids.
Once they mate and form a family unit, they'll
all live in the same territory, groom each
other and socialize.
It sounds all mid-century American family,
but gibbons know the difference between SOCIAL
monogamy and REPRODUCTIVE monogamy.
In gibbons, the female is the head of the
family unit, then the offspring, and the male
is at the bottom.
Cheating and casual sex with other members
of the group happens and the monkeys will
even get a kind of divorce; separating from
their family groups and striking out on their
own.
Monogamy in nature is starting to look more
like human monogamy, eh?
Bald eagles mate for life too, once they've
picked their mate, the two eagles build a
nest together, returning to the same spot
year after year.
They expand the nest each time, so bald eagle
nests can grow to ten feet across and weigh
as much as half a ton.
The baby eaglets -- which is the CUTEST NAME
EVER -- are on their own four months after
birth and can live for 25 years!
That would be like you being kicked out at
11 months old.
Sounds rough to be an eagle.
Not to mention, the couple splits up and does
the long-distance thing during migration season
-- getting back together during mating season.
But the animal rated by me to be the most
passionate, the most pure -- is the prairie
vole.
A study in Nature Neuroscience found when
a male vole and a single female vole meet
their brains are irrevocably altered by massive
release of oxytocin and vasopressin.
Their gene switch, and boom they're addicted
to each other, they work together, play together
and if he needs to he'll fight for her like
the Dredd Pirate Roberts.
Though, funnily, if you give the guy a bit
of alcohol -- he'll go chill with a stranger
vole. #sigh...
Monogamy...
It's never easy, but it's out there.
And messing with it can be REAL bad.
What do you think?
Do you have a favorite animal that mates for
life?
If you believe in monogamy tell us below,
and if not, why!
Let's talk about it.
You can also come find us on twitter at-DNews
or come find me at-TraceDominguez.
Thanks for watching for more DNews, click
subscribe!